[Music]
jane's in phoenix hi jane welcome to the
ramsey show
hey dave hey what's up
awesome long time listener first time
caller
yes uh so anyway my my question is um
i'm 36 years old um i'm getting
unengaged
thank you
took us a long time to find each other
um anyway i uh
i have always since i was a little kid
like money equals security for me
and i've actually completed all of those
baby steps before i even knew who dave
ramsey was
and so i just want to tell you like
that's like a huge part of
you know what kind of makes me whole as
bad as that nice might sound but the
ultimate goal is you know financial
freedom
um you know i don't
i don't make money to go buy gucci
purses and stuff like that and i'm
betting the guy that you're marrying is
not a saving tight wad like you
that is correct opposites attract i've
heard
that that is also true you know he's the
the best man that he he treats me so
well he loves me so much it's just that
we had different upbringings when it
came to finances and so
i asked him to sign a prenup um because
i have built a little bit of a mistake
for myself what is a little bit of a
mistake
a million dollars okay and he has
nothing
yep exactly
he's got it he's got his car
yeah he's got his car okay now the good
the good thing is he was in some toxic
relationships in the past
and he has um
you know become a better version of
himself and he's learned from these
toxic relationships you know trying to
impress women with
with stuff right how old is he
42. okay been married before
he was married in his 20s but
uh nope never married no kid all right
cool
and uh so i asked him to sign a prenup
um because you know
finances are my security and
it would be very detrimental to me if
something didn't work out
and i lost half of that
so
he has been really cool and he uh
understands that just by knowing uh
what's your question
the question is how do i
dave how do i deal with like
someone that is not on the same
financial
you know
level as me not level in terms of income
because he could make that in his what
he does for work he could make that up
but like
how do i
how do i control my anxiety of like
right now i'll let john address that let
me back up about three steps and i want
to i want to hit i want to hit two
things and then i want him to step into
the relationship part of this too
um the
number one i do agree and i rarely
agree
but in your case the uh the difference
is so extreme and when there's an
extreme difference of a million dollars
or more
uh i do recommend a prenup so i do agree
with the prenup i don't agree with why
you did it
okay
you did it trying to protect where you
feel like security comes from
mistake
because security doesn't come from money
i mean it gives you some security it
gives you some sense of peace but you're
placing more on it than you should and
you actually said that right
right okay so i i don't want you uh
doing this to protect this from him i
just think it's general wisdom because
the differences are so extreme and i'll
even go a step further the reason that i
used to tell people never do a prenup
but the reason i started doing where the
differences are extreme is not you and
him but it's your wacky relatives
and they go well he married a
millionaire so i'm going to jump in here
and i got a whole agenda now and here
comes crazy eddie the cousin right and
something and you and he he's got a nice
barrier now he goes i got a prenup i
can't help so uh you know you can kind
of reel crazy eddie out at thanksgiving
dinner and so it shuts shuts down the
weirdness around these differences but
what you're identifying that john and i
can both speak to is that you have to
get
on the same page prior to marriage about
how we're going to handle money he's
never going to be as extreme as you are
and you're never going to be as loose as
he is but you've got to get each other
and you got to get closer together than
you are now because you're going to tear
each other's eyes out otherwise
here i'm going to i'm going to be real
honest with you is that cool
yeah yeah please i feel like you have a
part of you that you want to stay yours
and you want to build a brick wall
around it because this is mine
and then the rest of me i'm going to
marry out
you can't do that
that's not how your marriage is gonna
it's gonna end up he's not gonna ever
fully have you now i'm not saying he has
access to a million dollars in a
checking account i'll follow dave's uh
financial wisdom there what i'm saying
is
you have told him i don't find security
in you i don't find security in our
marriage i don't find security in the
same theology i find security in this
bank account that you can't touch now
let's get married and go make a life
together
so it's it's a sentiment it's a moving
forward so
i wouldn't start the conversation with
him we i handle money better than you
you never have i would start the
conversation like this
we are about to sign up for forever with
each other
and i'm only doing this once
here's what i need
having us on the same page with a budget
makes me feel safe it makes me feel
heard and it makes me be able to sleep
at night and he's gonna say
having you spend some money for us to go
dancing and go laugh a little bit and go
on vacation makes me feel seen and heard
and you can go cool i'm all in and he
can go cool i'm all in and he's gonna
have to learn some new tools that he
doesn't have so you're gonna have to be
patient with him and curious and
practice and you don't know how to cut
loose and spend some money and go
dancing and he's going to teach you how
to do that that's the beauty of this
thing moving forward if you both make it
a point to meet each other's needs the
best you can hear what i'm saying
yeah this is a core issue
and then i guess the other kind of
question i have john and dave is like um
i've never had to support someone and
right now he just recently switched jobs
and it takes a while to kind of build up
your book of business
and um right now i'm paying rent and i'm
also
giving him extra cash i have um when i
get paid i'm married
yeah right you don't give people cash
you're not married yeah okay he he
doesn't he is not making anything right
now and he needs to go do doordash yeah
he's gonna start moving live
he did he did get to sign up for uber so
i don't know the process of that but he
like he can make money tonight go door
knocking you got to he's got to figure
that out
and and
you when you get married it's y'all's
money
you're not paying his rent it's y'all's
money
yeah and one day you might lose your job
and he's working you're not you're not
supporting anyone when you're married
it's hours it's ours
right right well i am supporting him
right now
giving me anxiety yeah that should give
you anxiety
and if this is if he's if he's giving
you a if he's giving you a precursor of
what's to come
and you can't sleep at night don't marry
this person or at least have some hard
conversations with a marriage therapist
really quick like pre-marital counseling
yeah yeah yeah we we do have a counselor
that that we talk to so that yeah you've
got to get this to where he
um is demonstrating that he can stand on
his own
and uh
because that's going to free every time
that's going to freak you out and it's
going to freak you out more than
everybody else it will freak out anybody
but it's going to freak you out even
more because of the way you're wired
right i mean you've got to be kind of
like weighing like waking up at 2 30 in
the morning going
right now right yeah did you wake up did
you wake up i mean did you did you grow
up financially insecure
uh not insecure but my dad and mom like
they uh you know there was some um
cheating that happened so as a young kid
i was like that's it i'm gonna provide
for myself so at the age of eight i
started saving my money so let me tell
you this let me tell you this
that's trauma
and i want you to go to a counselor by
yourself
yeah and i want you to i want you to
tell them i need to learn how to
accept connection in my life and stop
relying on this imaginary pot of money
it's not imagine the pot the pots really
safety's imaginary i want to learn how
to find security in relationships and
i've never been able to do that and i
need to learn those skills that's your
new assignment moving forward yeah and
and don't give people money too that
you're not married
to
that he needs to go work extra
and he should want to